cerca de la una de la tarde del 9 de
enero de 2015
américo olivari entró en el supermercado
ubicado en porte vansen con un rifle de
asalto disparó y mató a cuatro personas
tomó 28 rehenes entre ellos la sana
batir y un empleado del local en medio
de la confusión el joven maliense logra
esconder seis rehenes entre ellos un
bebé en el sótano de la tienda luego
apagó la electricidad y pidió que
apagarán sus teléfonos antes de correr
por una salida de seguridad al verlo la
policía lo señaló como cómplice del
terrorista
me esposaron permaneció esposado durante
una hora y media hacían las mismas
preguntas yo les daba las mismas
respuestas una y otra vez cuántos de
ustedes están ahí pensé que estaban
preguntando cuántos rehenes así que les
dije que habían unos 15 dijeron 15
terroristas fue entonces cuando me di
cuenta de que estaban hablando de los
terroristas así que les dije que yo no
era uno de ellos pero no me creyeron
finalmente fue identificado el jefe
policial a cargo de la operación obtuvo
de él información valiosa como el
escondite de los rehenes no sé a postes
sets
ximo sola ellos permitió trazar planos
de la tienda eliminando algunas
hipótesis como nuestra idea inicial de
romper la pared del sótano con
explosivos la sala batilly nos dijo que
no nos llevaría a donde queríamos irse
su contribución fue crucial el angulero
se personase la escena aquí
personal en boston
[Música]
cuatro horas después de la toma de
rehenes comenzó la acción de la policía
cool y bali disparó en contra de los
oficiales y murió durante el tiroteo los
28 rehenes fueron liberados sólo uno
quedó herido pero todos vivos en los
días siguientes la sana fue condecorado
y recibió la ciudadanía ahora los
presuntos cómplices de cool y bali serán
juzgados
la sana estará allí para escuchar su
testimonio
para mí es muy importante saber la
verdad entender lo que pasó en el área
del techo es que se pase